hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream Q and A of the
147th episode
something along those lines hello
subscribe okay keep going uh I think I
was done oh
that's my sense
all right well it's us again ah that is
quite right Brett Weinstein Heather Hein
thank you for the reminder and Madison
yes of course named after James even
though she's a girl yep ah we can honor
James with uh
you know a dog that identifies as
whatever gender they do no she does not
nope
all right fine our dog has no gender
identity I feel constrained by your
obligation to realize
[Laughter]
well
I guess there's nothing to do but to uh
I don't know winch ourself
out of this awkward situation by
addressing questions that have been
posed winch
no no no it's a metaphor if you had if
your jeep was mired in the muck yes and
it had a winch you could hook it to
something and winch yourself out of the
uh The Quagmire remember that uh yeah
book duck in a truck
that Rings about you yeah the children's
book that I at least used to read to our
children a lot it was a duck and a truck
get stuck in a muck and uh I think they
do not ever use the f word in that book
but they use all the other words ended
uck uh the duck driving the truck get
stuck in the muck and what is he gonna
do about it yeah yeah
um I don't think he ends up with a winch
but I don't remember actually well winch
wouldn't rhyme right um yeah but I don't
not every word in the book Rhymes
because that's not how rhyming works one
word rhymes yes right at the very end
yeah yeah all right um I I vaguely
remember this it was it was good duck in
a truck I I I recommend it you know
being fond of it 18 months to
five-year-old or something yeah yeah or
anyone behaving like that like a duck in
a truck no behaving like there
getting stuck in the muck but you know
toddlers too yeah exactly to
kindergarten yeah exactly all right
um from the Discord this week we invite
um
the people on our Discord
every week to consider what question
they would most like us to ask and the
vote winner this week no
we we do the answering we do the answer
they yeah they vote on which question
they would like us to answer yes yes
this isn't going to be very effective
this week I'm afraid guys is that right
yeah no no I think this is I'm taking
responsibility for that that's on me all
right so it's up to you to raise the I'm
gonna rally
yeah yeah all right rise to the
challenge yep what this is a good
question though we can do this yeah what
is your evolutionary opinion about
toothpaste are there toxins and
trade-offs what did our ancestors do
without it
that is a great question yeah I love
this it's a good question yeah uh I have
often thought
that toothpaste
is a bit like lip balm
which is to say once you start using it
you become convinced and maybe even come
to kind of need it because now uh your
lips or your mouth depending aren't
doing quite as much of the things as
they would be doing otherwise and of
course there are more extreme examples
like
you know taking exogenous hormones right
or melatonin or you know in anything
that you might put into or on your body
um that replaces a function that your
body might have other already had May
signal to your body okay we already got
enough of that so we're not going to
produce as much now going forward even
if you stopped so now you can't stop and
so now you're just sort of stuck with
the thing
um
certainly you know brush on your teeth
uh is is a different question from
what's going on with toothpaste so
toothpaste has how much how many
roles do we think we are told in this
but a long time since I've seen any
toothpaste advertising but you know it's
like freshening
it's fluoride
what else I mean some of them are
claiming to be whitening at this point
it's abrasive that's the key thing about
identifrus yeah although a brush is the
biggest abrasive so why why would you
need to add a thing for the uh
abrasion because the hardness of the
brush is insufficient to do the job
seems to me like that's actually that
that runs counter to what you should
want it seems like you're going to wear
through your enamel if you're using
toothpaste as well let's I mean the most
modern toothbrush taste is very smooth
uh not not at Finance scale Sandy
that's Zach oh Zach
um what do you think
he was about to say it anyway
so here's the thing obviously there's
something weird about toothpaste in the
sense that
uh the Ancients didn't have it and we
think we need it now if you were going
to make a defense of the need you would
say well we live longer and as with
other uh creatures whose teeth
whose teeth have been scaled to the life
length who are now out living their
teeth like elephants in the zoo who run
out of teeth or teeth are basically on a
conveyor belt and they have a fixed
number on like sharks and they run out
of teeth
it one of the things that is true is
that our teeth have to last longer than
our ancestors Teeth did because our
average lives are so much longer
so it could be that we are becoming
extra careful about Decay processes that
um our ancestors had to worry less about
it could be
that the novel diet is creating hazards
to our teeth that didn't exist for
ancestors it's certainly true uh that uh
the Western price and Mike mu of the
matter is that we have
but done we have arbitrarily compromised
ourselves so that things like
malocclusion result in extra wear on
some teeth and nowhere on other teeth so
you could be compensating for this sort
of thing and there's some interesting
questions around
the freshness thing
I strongly suspect is the result of the
fact that we are not any longer part of
a population where we're all eating the
same thing and all have the same mouth
flora and all of that which I suspect
would eliminate the uh the bad smells
that often occur when somebody's eating
something different and it's being
digested by different bacteria than you
have and it results in byproducts that
are offensive and all of that so yeah
but I'm still I'm not compelled I don't
I don't know the history of toothpaste
and I wouldn't be shocked if it turns
out to have been an entirely corporate
move right with no basis in in Research
into its its benefit because it it seems
to me
that like a saline rinse and a brush
with no toothpaste on it at all like I
If if you told me I had to go for six
months travel somewhere and I had to you
know either not have usually I wear
contact lenses I don't on on camera but
you know if I had to go with that saline
solution or toothpaste or like I don't
know I love this like this Pharaoh
um uh lard based skin moisturizer which
I do think like skin moisturizer too is
one of these things like obviously
people didn't have it before but like if
I had to choose one of those three
things to go without obviously be
toothpaste yeah now if you told me I
couldn't have a toothbrush that's huge
like that would and you know I also like
floss and you know water floss or
something there's lots of things sort of
in that territory that I really like and
use daily but I actually find that
toothpaste is by far the least valuable
of the tooth care products for me among
the things that I use and and care about
and it strikes me like really it's the
freshness thing like you wake up in the
morning and you want to not smell
yourself and wonder if you smell well
after a night of sleeping with I think
you're right you know in a in a
community where not everyone is eating
the same thing and therefore we don't
share the same mouth flora and fauna but
in terms of sort of abrasiveness and
getting stuff out of your teeth
um I mean especially if we're talking
about having modern tech a toothbrush
without toothpaste floss and a water
flosser uh
and good yep
um I am as you know also not a
toothpaste historian
um wait
I feel like it's all been a lie
no no I told you this at first you may
not have believed me you may I feel like
you let me continue to think that that
was true
at worst is a sin of omission
um yes I'm gonna have to think about
this I am no toothpaste historian okay I
agree with you that this is likely I
mean in one regard
um
the fluoride itself
uh anyone who digs into this discovers
that fluoride is a um industrial
byproduct it is industrial byproduct and
it is anything but clear a there's a
question about which which fluoride salt
actually there's any data at all to
suggest it's good for you B there's
downsides to it
etc etc but C the fluoride salt that
gets put into toothpaste is not the
right one that's certainly true for
fluoridated water I don't remember what
the answer is oh okay okay good but in
any case
um
the I've always wondered if
a we're interrupting a natural process
it is interesting that the stuff that
accumulates on your teeth and I forget
which one is Tartar and which one's
plaque plaque must be the hard stuff I
think so yeah
um interesting that it is roughly tooth
colored
right and it's a question about what if
you allowed your mouth to come to
equilibrium would you actually be worse
off or is Dentistry doing what
Orthodontics has done and you know
creating its own needs right every six
months definitely twice a year you need
to get all that stuff taken off your
teeth really every six months you say
everything how do you arrive at that
number yeah well
um so anyway there there is a deep
question here and you know okay you're
taking an abrasive to teeth hopefully
it's been fine-tuned so that you know a
softer substance can't damage a harder
substance so you would have to calibrate
exactly what substance it was so that
you were taking off the plaque and
tartar and not taking off any enamel at
all and wouldn't it at least put a risk
of like if you've got
if you've got a tiny little hole in your
enamel if you've got a tiny little
cavity wouldn't the abrasive inherently
work to make it bigger well if it is not
as hard as the tooth enamel then I think
not
um no but if there's already a little
hole and then some abrasive gets
underneath into like the Dentin or
whatever it is well but it you know it's
a little bit like um
you know those Scotch Brite
uh pads and sponges that have it there's
like different grades and there's
certain stuff that you can't do with you
know the blue one that you can do with
the green one
um so you know there's a there is a
basic hardness or just different grits
on sandpaper yeah well different grits
is about size
um the hardness is the key the Scotch
Brite thing is a hardness of material
yeah yeah it is
um and so anyway don't know the answer
to the question I do suspect that there
is some face palm at the end of
Dentistry where we understand that much
of the interfering we did wasn't really
in our interests obviously there's a
certain amount of interfering that we do
that is about things like living longer
and your teeth having to last longer
than they were built for and that sort
of thing
um but but by and large yes I says oh I
I want to point this out I believe there
is a marvelous piece with uh Richard
Feynman in which teeth yeah which he
points out that the world is full of
people engaging in this Behavior a
couple times a day and that there's no
evidence whatsoever that it's good for
you if I recall the piece correctly
um and uh anyway I don't know if that's
still true
um I assume it was true when he said it
and I believe I have remembered it
correctly
um but yes there's no question that this
is
a significant intervention that
it could be a compensation for novelty
stuff which would be the best defense
for it or it could be that this is
um a cultivated need that is about
somebody else's economic well-being and
and those sorts of things and uh anyway
it would certainly be worth knowing
keep keep going for yourself wow okay
sorry about teeth just yes I gotta look
something up quickly that that reminded
me of all right that's something I don't
know if you've ever noticed this but we
have teeth in both our upper jaw and our
lower jaw and uh the dentry is the the
lower jaw am I correct about that Dr
Hein um what I was looking up the thing
yeah and what
yes lower jaw
yes yes
um is the upper jaw the arcade do I have
that right
no no
dental work
um what are we talking about I don't
know teeth I'm trying to rip so I asked
you to give me a break so I could look
something up and now you're asking like
you want me to look up I did no no no I
did a terrible job yeah you really did
like that was like ex like really you
were actively getting in my way well I
have now come to the conclusion that I'm
there is no bone called an arcade
against there's a dental arcade that's
fine but there's no bone called an
arcade okay all right fair enough you're
probably thinking of a place where you
go to play games uh no no that's a whole
different ball game
um yeah yeah uh so
I was reminded of the uh the conceit
that Ricky Gervais does on Twitter every
now and again when I said if I had to go
somewhere for six months with and I had
to I could only take two of these three
things I would very easily give up
toothpaste
um but it turns out he does this a lot
so I was I was going to just ask you one
of these
um
but the one that came up I've never seen
before so it's it's maybe a little a
little tough but uh
okay you ready sure this is Ricky
Gervais on Twitter you can only keep
three all right okay and the list is one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven twelve thirteen it's it's
long so you can only keep three of these
12 things three of these twelve things
yeah all right makeup
driving
mobile phone
alcohol
pets
TV
dancing
novels haircuts
passport
sick pay
first of all if I said anything
different I would be in danger at this
moment right your pets is on the list
yeah they're all here looking at you
passport and
um you know I had a little brush with uh
so to speak I had a little brush with
not having a haircut while I was in
Columbia you know I I thought that I was
in so the hair goes into this phase
right there's a phase where it's
decently behaved and then there's a
phase at which it gets pretty unruly and
then it will sometimes come back into
well-behavior so you still haven't had a
haircut what you should point out no I
haven't had a haircut and the thing is
um I'm a little afraid too because I had
this one very traumatic experience when
we moved to Olympia my first haircut
um she was hostile oh she hated you I
think she really I don't know why she
hated it but she asked me what I wanted
her to do and I said something like well
you're the expert and she was she got a
little testy
you know it was also one of these like
Super Cuts knockoffs yeah it wasn't even
super cool it was Super Cuts but no it
was it wasn't but but in any case she I
think didn't like me and she gave me
um an objectively terrible haircut and
it was one it was short enough that
there wasn't really any correction to do
other than possible somehow almost
almost shaved and yet still wildly
asymmetrical it was like that it was a
really bad haircut and so anyway I'm a
little traumatized having now just moved
that I need to find someone to cut my
hair and
so anyway I despite that you're gonna
haircut's gonna be on your list that's
the thing is I know what happens if I
don't have one and my little visit to
Columbia
was a strong hint in this direction
where I think I look increasingly like a
crazy person and
um so anyway I think out of necessity
certainly if I'm going to have a
passport I'm going to need a haircut I'm
not giving up pets so that's my answer
wow okay
um just to repeat yeah what you are
giving up then makeup easy driving
yeah I could do it bread for you that's
easy now slam dunk mobile phone yep
alcohol
I'll live with it
TV yep dancing
yeah
novels yeah
sick pay
we don't get sick pay yeah so for me I'm
there's no way haircuts going on my list
um
[Music]
novels yeah yeah right for me yeah of
course yeah all right you know a day in
which I don't get to read some
some long-form fiction is not not nearly
as good
so but otherwise yeah I mean I guess
there's always with these uh the
question of like well in a world without
some of the like how is a world about
these things requiring a passport like
can't you just sort of sneak in like
that's sort of thing well but I don't
take the question as if you had to give
up it's not if you had to live in a
world without these things it's if you
had to give up your particular thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I think this is
the easiest one
um okay we're gonna find another one
should I go to the questions okay well
it also if we if we'll go to the
questions and then if uh if there aren't
uh well it logged me out
um
come on
um there we go
if we don't have enough questions
like prioritizing haircuts over driving
is kind I mean I enjoy driving to an
extent but it's kind of a necessary evil
it's not keep adding more things to your
driving repertoire
I mean if I'm gonna drive but
um
yeah I I wouldn't mind if I could give
up driving
though how are you gonna get places it
is free yeah you know where I drove over
the weekend well I'm a sector of 1700
miles I'm a man because he's an
excellent grandson who was setting up a
computer of my mother his grandmother in
a few days and yeah over the course of a
two and a half I'm not imagining that
I'm
stuck in the absence of driving I'm
imagining well you think I'm gonna drive
you everywhere I get it fine fine no
actually he's gonna drive us everywhere
yeah
you can fly yeah
you can ride
okay
um oh look what we got here
it's gonna be interesting
um first question from
darkhorsesmissions.com this week
I've been thinking lately about the
effect of media on our thought processes
propaganda is an old tool it gained
power during movie and TV's rise what do
you think is the evolutionary effect of
this on individual and population level
functioning
um yeah so I think the question the
person is asked both about media and
well
media propaganda propaganda gaining
power because of the role because of
media's change as it became moving
pictures basically yeah I think there's
a bunch of things going on one
you have you know a primordial situation
where
you had no antagonists with access to
narrative creation right when you were
living in a band of people and you were
you had completely shared fate then the
point is whatever got encoded in that
was yeah it was about even if it was
wrong and bad for you it was not
intended
it was not indifferent to yourself
Trojan Horse was about as close to
propaganda as you could get like some
someone trying to sneak in something
that wasn't what it seemed yeah but the
point is in a in a band of in a lineage
a small lineage that's unlikely as soon
as you get Agriculture and therefore you
get large-scale culture and you get
religions you can get somebody borrowing
that voice to basically
alter the behavior of other people for
their own benefit
um which you know so that's early
propaganda
and then you get technology which does a
number of things not only does it
increase the range and Fidelity of the
propaganda
it also becomes sophisticated in being
able to refine the techniques involved
in propaganda so you know the idea
that
um you know
sexuality for example is going to be
used to persuade you of something but
not only is it going to be used but
um real humans may be the substrate that
is then modified in Photoshop for some
preter natural level of beauty that then
Alters you know the standard to which
actual humans have to Aspire right these
things are super destructive and the
point is it's it's technology in play
and this isn't really possible you know
you can have a sculpture or a painting
that distorts but the point is it also
connotes this isn't real by the very
nature of the medium in question but
when you have photorealistic
um pictures or you have
um you know moving pictures
and you have you know economics that
allow you know the
forces that be need to
basically borrow the body and you know
speech capacity of an individual and get
them to say things that that individual
has no personal relationship with all
these things are incredibly destructive
and so now we live in a world
and which if you literally think about
all of the times in the average day
that
somebody has an economic motive to
persuade you of something that's not in
your interest but is in their interest
it's like we get up in the morning and
we are
immediately bombarded with
high-tech [ __ ] right and it's just a
constant if if we turn on that device
that has an ability to
let's put it this way in order to avoid
it you have to go way out of your way
right the normal stuff of Life requires
you to interact with things over which
the [ __ ]
is transmitted and whether that's you
know emails trying to get you to buy
stuff that you don't need or it's
governmental propaganda about your
health or whatever it may be it is not
normal for a human being
to have antagonists hijacking their
perception that is just that is it's not
that it's without precedent
but the degree to which that has become
a dominant factor in what we perceive
from other humans and human-like
phenomena is
um
shocking and dangerous
true
this question
apparently there was a New York
gubernatorial debate this past week
a question about vaccine mandates came
up but it included both the coveted
facts and a polio vaccine
what polio is a thing is there a new
vaccine out are they using the old
vaccine used in the early part of the
last century
signed trapped in New York
I don't know anything about this this is
news to me I have no idea
why we're talking about polio vaccines
again that we dealt with that I thought
well it's definitely not extinct it's
not extinct
um foreign
it's not here
uh it's you know it it should and it
just there was just another little
little Resurgence somewhere I want to
say Africa although that might not be
right
um Africa maybe South Asia I'm not
totally sure
um
but it's not it's not in the American
vaccine schedule like we're not
we're not vaccinating against polio are
we I think we are
um but I don't they're not yeah but but
our children aren't uh it was it's not
it's not on the it's it hasn't been
what's that I'm pretty sure it's not
yeah it's not been on the recommended um
childhood vaccination schedule at least
at least for 20 years
so the problem is that we now know
because of what we've just seen that
there is no Safeguard to somebody
deciding to create the impression of
need for a product that they can sell
and to use right
um to use governmental coercion to
substitute for demand so I would say but
I mean this just seems this looks if
it's that it's really ham-fisted it's
like polio come on guys like there's
blood like well scarce was something
else you know like let's put it this way
what we actually need is an actual
entity capable of doing an actual cost
or risk benefit analysis and the risk
benefit analysis does not say just
because uh polio is not here that the
vaccine should not be administered
though in practice it would say that
almost every time because in order to
get if you wanted to say well
what we want to do is prevent her from
being polio here
it's not here but it does circulate out
there and there's no barrier between
here and there and if the risks
associated with the vaccine were really
close to zero which a I think they're
not and B that logic means that anything
any tropical disease for which there is
a good vaccine every American child
should be vaccinated like okay vaccine's
yellow fever well no no no because the
vector isn't here
in the case of yellow fever okay so if
it's a vector disease if it's a
tropically if the tropical disease that
is vectored and the vector can't live up
here okay yeah but you're saying
um cholera so now the color of vaccine
is crap like everyone knows this cholera
vaccine is crap and the treatment is
readily available yeah but it's not
vectored but let's let's put it this way
I have steel manned the case if the car
if the risk associated with the polio
vaccine was
vanishingly close to zero then you could
make an argument for it's a very serious
disease we don't want it to have an
outbreak here we should vaccinate
everybody however
as biologists
you have to include both the known harms
and their rate and a term for what you
don't know about the impact and we know
so little about the impact of let's say
cumulative vaccinations across all the
different diseases that we vaccinate for
we know so little about things like uh
you know original antigenic sin and its
impact on not only the disease in
question but also alternative diseases
we know so little about the selection
for variants Etc that it is impossible
to imagine a term for potential risk
involved with this vaccine that is not
substantial
yes and I guess I would also say there
is some moment
between let's just make it broad between
50 and 20 years ago when what had been
an expected required vaccine
um that every American under two or
something got became one that no one got
what was the logic behind that move and
what has changed to suggest reversing
that move
like it seems to me that in this
particular case
for a while all Americans were being
vaccinated against this disease and then
that changed and if we're talking about
a change to a prior State we we have to
have a full explanation of why you know
what it is that is being imagined has
moved us back into a position more like
whatever it's going to be you know 50
years ago and even a full explanation at
this point given you know that it's what
we've seen with the fraudulent [ __ ]
over
you know for example uh Ivermectin yeah
right
you would have to do a lot of digging to
make sure that the rationale that was
put in front of you was actually robust
and that the you know the references
that were used to support it were
actually what they claim to be right
that work has to be done now this is of
course what these institutions are for
but there's not a single one that works
yep
so yep yeah it's it's a it's a crazy
moment and I think a lot of us are now
awake to the fact that things that we
accepted before as worth the risk on the
basis of the benefit on the basis of
doing our part for immunity that all of
these things are now in question because
we don't know how long the system has
been compromised and at what level
that's right
oh before we move on to the next
question I just want to point out that
we've got Maddie who is sleep running
and uh Tesla who is lying on one of the
dog's sleep running legs and at least
until a moment ago had his chin resting
on her paws so he may be about to be
sleep kicked into Oblivion on air yeah
and he will forgive the dog because he's
that kind of cat but he won't appreciate
it no yeah
um this is just a logistical question do
you guys see your patreon message
inboxes or is there an email address I
might be able to contact I sent a couple
of messages about the startup I've been
mentioning I think you might be
generally interested not trying to sneak
in an advert whiskey Tuesday on the
Discord if someone wants to reply
Incognito
um I do see my patreon message inbox but
I'm way behind on it uh someone else
reads Brett's and he's supposed to get
um
some some number of uh things that come
in through there but we do have email
addresses on our on our websites
um as well um that that do get monitored
so
those may be more more direct to get to
us
yeah and I don't know just from this
description if I've seen because a lot a
lot of people write in with a lot of
ideas and proposals and so it is true
that we don't we don't respond to even
close to a majority of them even though
that does mean that for sure we're
missing a lot of good opportunities
my doc and others have told me that mRNA
vaccines are nothing new
HPV vaccine is an example of mRNA
technology that has been around for a
while are they different than the covid
shots
now I don't
what
that's not sure if he's not an mRNA
vaccine it's not an mRNA vaccine I'm
just going I'm gonna go to the CDC well
Utah I'm going to go and say about HPV
vaccine is current a CDC what do they
say you can talk so I'll say a couple
things one
um the HPV vaccine is a troubling
vaccine
it is a vaccine that has an asymmetry in
it that ought to alert us that we are
not having the discussions that we
should have because the negative
consequences of HPV largely fall on
females which is unfair but true
and so the question is when did we have
the discussion as a society about
whether or not to vaccinate males who
are not at risk for the benefit of
females now a reasonable person can
certainly make an argument for that but
the question is
did we decide that that is the kind of
thing we are going to engage in right
where an individual is compelled to be
vaccinated for a disease that does not
pose a serious risk to them
um
for the benefit of others in which case
that leads us directly to the question
about vaccinating young people for covid
at a significant risk in order
ostensibly to possibly help older people
which doesn't make any sense because of
course they don't block transmission but
anyway HPV is a complex
non-simple
um
place where we've been given an overly
simplified story it is not the case that
this is the same technology in the uh
coveted mRNA Vox vaccines by a long shot
that said I do not remember what the
underlying technology is in yeah and
it's not
I'm not financed on the CDC site I'm at
one paper now published
in 2015 in viral Immunology the first
called human papillomavirus
vaccine-induced cytokine messenger RNA
expression in vaccinated women
um
but the first sense of the abstract even
though they end up talking about mRNA in
the abstract sum
the objective of this work is to
evaluate the influence of human
papilloma pep I don't even know where
the accent's supposed to go HPV
what's that human papillomavirus
Paloma
Pablo so you just dropped that initial I
papilloma really is that right I think
so okay
um I'm gonna call it HPV
um the objective of this works to
evaluate the influence of HPV
vaccination on peripheral blood
mononuclear cell pbmc proliferation and
cytokine Gene transcription and then
only two-thirds the way into this
abstract they're saying cytokine mrnas
were upregulated and stimulated pbmc
cultures but I I in a very admittedly
very very research I'm finding nothing
about what the and it's I think it's a
Gardasil I don't I can't find exactly
what it what it is what its mechanism is
but
um
I think this is just [ __ ] it's
nonsense yeah yeah
um
now I have to find my
phone here we go
if Ivermectin is so safe and works for
covid would it not work for other
viruses should we think about making
Ivermectin a widely available
non-prescription treatment for flu
I've never heard anything to suggest
that it's effective against flu I don't
not to say that it doesn't but I've
never I've never been into that
um and it is
um boy in that piece
uh that we wrote
back one of my first sub Stacks that we
co-wrote back July 30th 2021 on driving
Stars Kobe 2 extinct
uh we included a list of
um
various viruses that it is known uh to
be effective against and here's just a
few uh in 2012 Ivermectin was found to
be a quote highly potent inhibitor of
replication of the yellow fever virus
eight years on that is to say in 2020 a
systematic review found that Ivermectin
was effective against a wide range of
RNA viruses including but not limited to
West Nile Dengue zika and tick-borne
encephalitis
and that's a that's a tiny subset of the
list of um RNA viruses that Ivermectin
is known to be effective against I don't
think flu I don't I've never I don't I
don't think we know obviously we've got
to study what it works against
um and yes it should be available in one
way or another prescribable for those
things for which it works and of course
there's a big antagonist it's not going
to be patentable right you know under
any circumstances and so yeah
um you know Pharma ain't gonna like the
idea that there's a cheap safe
alternative to disease when they have
expensive stuff that they can get
liability protection for and
um
cell
get the government to coerce people to
take so
music emerge as a training program for
the bipedal station for instance
toddlers vocalize while learning to walk
opera singers have a specific posture
for their voices to be harmonious and
strong
um
this is one of these questions I am
going to hold back on a little bit
because I've got some active work
stuff that actually goes back
um to when I was a college student
I would say the thing about music is it
is logically true that it has to start
for a reason a particular reason
what is also true is that music has many
different functions uh ultimately and so
the question is what is the original
function that then gets elaborated into
these other things what you're
describing I do not believe to be the
original function but I do believe to be
a function
um and let's just say this is a very old
question Darwin spotted it what the hell
is music
um
uh Stephen Pinker
wildly screwed up the answer
um where he famously said that music
contains all sorts of things uh that are
useful but itself is not useful that
it's the equivalent of evolutionary
cheesecake where you just you know do we
have a desire for cheesecake no we have
a desire for fat and sugar and
various nutrients and so that makes
cheesecake yummy but it doesn't have a
meaning of its own it's actually I've
never heard you describe his position
quite that way before and it's just so
explicitly reductionist yeah nice
absolutely reductionist yeah
um
so anyway uh stay tuned I do I do hope
to bring a evolutionary theory of Music
forward I think there's a good one and
it's pretty satisfying but I'm not not
ready to go there
all right
um
the next question I was just trying
we don't have business we're not in our
studio we don't have all the usual
things that I would have on hand that I
usually have on hand
so the next question
is excuse me
what are your must reads in the field of
philosophy and anthropology
thank you for all you do
and I thought starting actually with the
books that we recommend at the end of
funder gatherers guide is it's there
aren't there are definitely some
philosophical things missing there but
um well you know I
I recommend this book this this is Pages
280 through 282 or whatever yeah uh in
the book but with regard to
anthropological readings in particular
um
we have Nisa the life and words of a
Kung woman
and
we have and this is not exactly
anthropology but kind of is 1491 New
Revelations for the Americas before
Columbus by Charles Mann
we have
um
gun streams of Steel the um I'm just
going in order here uh
Catching Fire how cooking made us Human
by Richard rangham which is fantastic
the evolution of Desire strategies with
human mating by bus and why sex Matters
by Bobby Lowe I think even higher on my
list than Guns Germs and Steel because I
gotta say I just find um Jared Diamond's
thinking extraordinary but his writing
is really not terrific I find I find it
very hard to get through his stuff
Mother Nature history of mothers infants
and natural selection by Sarah black for
hurting is probably the top of my book
on top of my list on anthropology let me
just get through the rest of this
um
the anthropology of childhood cherbs
Channel changelings by Lancey
uh plenty more here there's at least one
more that I'm forget ah then probably my
other favorite is baboon metaphysics the
evolution of a social Mind by Jane and
say forth
and then we got some Duval books and and
such but uh yes Guns Germs and Steel oh
and behave the biology of humans at our
best and worst episcopalsky
I gotta defend Diamond here irrespective
of his writing style which I don't find
that difficult
um the book is too long I think he wrote
it expecting pushback that actually
you know he got pushed back from
uh
people who I think felt that he was
competing with them but he did not get
the uh onslaught of accusations about
what he revealed that I think he was
expecting so the book could have been a
good deal shorter well people people I
hate it okay from the social sciences
you tell me that they uh they call me
geographical determinists yes they do
um it's amazing yeah it's a it's a it's
absurd but my point is that's academic
territoriality it's not a moral critique
it's not you know oh as I said I think
the ideas are necessary and critical I
just think the book is um he would have
done himself a service by um you know
putting out another book afterwards that
had a really good editor and uh and it
was a lot shorter and busier yeah but
irrespective the point is the concept in
the book The few concepts are so crucial
to understanding what our species is and
how it works that it almost doesn't
matter
um how it's written because the point is
you you the the the power tool that is
contained in the book is so important
that you have to get it somehow and but
you don't have to get it by reading the
book right you can do it by looking at
their documentary or you know looking up
YouTube videos on it like you don't in
that case whereas
um baboon metaphysics and mother nature
I both feel like actually you really
need to go into those books and the
other and the random book Catching Fire
is very very short and yes it's one key
idea that you know that it was fire and
cooking our food
um that that caused the cognitive
expansion that basically made us human
uh so I just said it on the other hand
that book is so short and so well
written and so incisive like I just like
you know read that even though I can
tell you in a sentence and I could tell
you in a paragraph and I could tell you
in an hour read the book and you'll get
more out of it yep I mean I do think uh
if you're not going to read guns and
Germs and Steel the three hour PBS
documentary
definitely leave some important stuff
out but you can get the gist of it and
then you could go back and read the book
and it would be clearer
um
but yeah it's a great three hours right
it's it's definitely the the core ideas
without some of the supporting
um
supporting information and it doesn't
show as much of his process but yeah
um but it's good
and then with regard to most trades in
the field of philosophy I'm not sure
I haven't either you know I have
philosophers and you know we've got some
popper on our shelves uh that is
probably the you know the philosopher of
science specifically that I would say I
would go to first if I had to choose one
um but I'm even less likely to read
philosophy um uh than
say Jared diamond right yeah it tends to
be very uh
very stayed and hard to get through so
uh our new friend Steve Patterson said
something I like on this topic okay he
says philosophy is where it's at but
philosophers aren't
right I thought captured it okay yep
and you know and this this is also borne
out by and this is more political
philosophy if you will but like what do
we remember of Orwell and like I've now
read a bunch of non-fiction Orwell and
he's actually he's great he's an
excellent writer and he's an excellent
basically culture Anthropologist yeah uh
but still you know we remember we
remember Fiction more easily so we
remember we remember it when it's told
through narrative more easily than when
it's told as the you know straight up
uh straight up philosophy and I think
gosh there's there's at least a couple
of those dancing novels that just get
you know dragged into explicit like
someone just extemporate extemporizes
for you know tens dozens even 100 Pages
a Time some character he hands them the
Rams and they just go off on philosophy
you know you your job here as a novel is
supposed to do that through narrative
not to have someone give a speech that
literally no one is listening to
pop-up book
okay Brett have you heard of nudge units
before their existence raises some
ethical concerns for me
um I am somewhat newly aware of the idea
of
nudging and I'm not sure that this is
what you're talking about but this is
basically
um
maneuvering a population through a kind
of gentle coercion
and while
coercion is an honorable and defensible
part of good governance this nudge thing
to the extent that I've encountered it
seems to me like a malignant version of
it that takes Liberties it shouldn't if
I'm wrong about that feel free to point
me in the right direction well when I
Google nudge unit yeah the first thing
that comes up is
University of Pennsylvania's
uh medicine nudge unit
introducing the new director of the Penn
Medicine nudge unit uh brings a wealth
of experience to the role with a history
of leading successful high impact
Behavioral Science interventions
so that sounds like it's consistent with
what you're talking about but it also
sounds like there are medical schools
now who are implementing things that
they are formally calling nudge units
unit to support five new projects for
advancing care
um
yeah using behavioral economics to
improve Healthcare quality here's one
but here's the problem is that is there
a problem here there's a problem the
problem is this that traditionally
medical schools have been really deeply
involved in medicine and medicine has
completely [ __ ] imploded over covid
and the failure of doctors to stand up
and say anything useful in the face of
obvious idiocy medicine has been
revealed to have become an empty suit
over covid having long since given up
diagnosis and having never embraced an
evolutionary understanding of the human
body such that at the point that covet
happens and the authorities come through
with their just take this most doctors
don't have the wherewithal or the like
logical ability to say wait why
no that's true in a sense but I actually
think
medicine existed three years ago right
it was a mixed bag you could go to the
doctor there was plenty of theatrogenic
harm right lots of people died as a
result of medical errors it was it was a
[ __ ] show however
there was an argument to be made
a strong argument to be made that it was
net positive and that you could in fact
increase the degree to which it was net
positive by avoiding doctors on certain
topics and engaging them on others
I don't think that's where we are now
because what they did
I think their smartest move was to
co-opt the doctors first and by getting
the doctors on board with the vaccine
campaign before it was clear how insane
it was they made it very hard for
doctors to back out of their position
and stand up and say wait a minute I was
wrong and so basically what they've now
done is they've taken a
highly compromised field but a
functional one and they have made it so
that those of us
[Music]
saw this go down in real time can't
really interact with any doctor who
hasn't stood up yet because
if they don't know it's on them the
pattern is in front of them
I was curious if you would peruse the
Annenberg inclusion initiative web page
in my opinion it's the source of much of
the propaganda is popular media cultural
assaults
never heard of the Annenberg inclusion
initiative
have you no is this associated with the
University of Pennsylvania
okay
um the Edinburgh inclusion initiative
says its own site is the leading think
tank in the world studying diversity and
inclusion and entertainment through
original research and sponsored projects
what could possibly go right yeah well
you know I don't know
I would be mildly surprised if USC was
the source of all of the madness but
yeah no but I do see a route here I mean
if I'm this is all new to me but if
okay USC
centered near Hollywood Hollywood being
particularly vulnerable to this kind of
embrace of nice sounding
Trojan Horse Concepts
um and also being
particularly capable of the kind of
social
exclusion that is Downstream of all of
this talk of inclusion
so it is possible that the proximity
yeah of USC to Hollywood means that this
thing has a straight shot to the rest of
the world through media
okay
um
they got four accelerator programs
listed on their page
okay two of them
seem the last two
seem reasonable the snap Originals will
support a rising senior film student
um working on unscripted content who has
a particular interest in short form
mobile storytelling the last one is
designed to support a rising senior film
student who wants to tell large-scale
scripted stories like comic book VFX
driven Etc make an impact on the
industry okay cool at least what they
say there at least what they say there
right the first two initiatives that
they mentioned though
um
thank you
I actually so it's weirdly organized
um the first one which doesn't have a
title is less than two percent of top
grossing film directors or women of
color yet films by women of color are in
the highest critical reviews
really
the ongoing disparities facing women of
color as directories Demand Action thus
Stacy L Smith and the Annenberg
inclusion initiative are launching the
all accelerator
this is the first program from the
Annenberg inclusion initiative to
directly support filmmakers and just
bolster the pipeline for young creatives
so it's possible actually that all of
these including the two that I thought
were awesome are Downstream of this
claim that I do not believe
the first part I believe less than two
percent of top gross and film directors
are women of color
yet films by women of color earn the
highest critical views now let's
spend some time on that sentence sure
they don't say less than two percent of
film directors or women of color get
films by women of color earn the highest
critical reviews
less than two percent of top grossing
film directors now that's the audience
voting with their feet top grossing is
about now yes there's PR there's
marketing you know do the you know are
there are there 10 of film directors or
women of color probably not but
um are they and then only only a fifth
of those uh are in a position where
their films are put in enough audience
and enough theaters to to gross big
maybe but you know films that start
small and become huge happen and they
get into bigger and bigger theaters
bigger bigger markets so uh I don't
that's that's a little trick there top
grossing like top grossing is about what
the audience is interested in seeing
um and then also yet films by women of
color earn the highest critical reviews
right which could mean a tiny number of
reviews that are on average you know
there are three reviews and they're five
stars right right or that the critics
are just as critics are woke now of
course and instead of actually reviewing
the art on the merits of the art they
review the art on the merits of the Art
Plus Progressive stack points for how
many things that you've got going for
you and so if you're a woman of color
you immediately get a boost in the
critics ratings right and then cheating
there's the
zoom out question here which is I do not
believe that there is a pattern in which
Hollywood would rather or instinctively
excludes people who would be producing
the top grossing films right because of
their race a it would be the opposite
right right yes and B the point is it's
just bad business and it's a huge
opening for anybody who can figure out
that there's this untapped resource that
audiences love and it would therefore
you know a be undervalued right uh so
you could treat you could uh Arbitrage
the market yeah the point is yeah look
these are greedy bastards they're really
good at making money and to the extent
that their racism gets in the way of
them making money then somebody will
figure out how to put their racism aside
and make some money in it right you know
right so the whole idea is preposterous
because actually you know their claim is
that this is an untapped opportunity to
make money but if it was they would tap
it Hollywood Hollywood that's what it
does
um yep so yeah nonsense
nonsense and then they have the
Reproductive Rights accelerator will
support a minimum of four Rising senior
film students who have a story to tell
about Reproductive Rights
now at one level like okay
but at another level that's one of a few
number of Annenberg inclusion initiative
accelerator programs and well
there's also you know I would certainly
think it would be good if there was a
lot of narrative exploration of this
territory but the whole point is that by
describing it as Reproductive Rights
they suggest a uh an openness to all
things but it's pretty clear that the
implication is
um that exercising your right is
interfering with a pregnancy not
deciding to
to keep it yeah right and so
and one of the top things on their page
is a document called inequality and
thirteen hundred popular films examining
portrayals of gender race ethnicity
lgbtq and disability from 2007 to 2019.
oh yeah so it's a you know over 100 page
report if something I saw earlier is
right I haven't assessed that myself
basically a grievance report right it's
it's a and you know not to say that if
we had ongoing problems it wouldn't be
worth knowing but what are the chances
they did an honest job here
oh my goodness New Year no progress for
girls and women on screen
prevalence of girls and women is
speaking characters across 1300 films in
percentages in 2019
they say
that 34 34 of
characters
in the films they looked at
were female we're 24 34 of speaking
characters were female
in 2019
I'm not sure I buy that
well and even if even if it was true
then there's a question about
there's all sorts of questions there's
all sorts of questions with balanced
casts most stories actually don't exist
at sex ratio yep like there you know if
you have a family story if you have like
a three generation family story maybe
you should expect an even sex ratio at
least of people who show up in the story
even if they don't have equal time on
screen but you know a war story is not
gonna have it and you know like there's
just right almost no story is actually
gonna you shouldn't expect an equal sex
ratio on screen
um
of the hundred top films in 2019 43
depicted a girl or woman as a lead or
co-lead
and this is bad I don't like I don't
even know what to make of this right
okay no they're trying to hard code into
narrative and expectation of equality
that isn't mirrored by you know do you
want movies to be
produced based on stories worth telling
or do you want to tell the world what it
ought to be like in narrative do you I
mean you know it's just it's Utopia
nonsense it's absolutely true that
Hollywood took a while to uh portray in
most cases female characters with
honesty in any way that you would
actually you know realize that they're
real human beings yep and some of the
best shows we're not now talking about
films but I'm think like peaky blinders
yep what may be my favorite TV show ever
um is fantastic in part
um because you know it's it's about
gangsters it's about Gypsy gangsters you
know between World War one and World War
II in England uh and yet the female
characters are there and they are real I
don't think there's a single character
male or female in that show uh that is a
caricature or two-dimensional uh you
know they certainly have people you know
characters who show up in the background
and you're like oh right I remember him
does he even have a name right um and
that's going to happen in every show
that's yeah that's that's giant but uh
the the female characters are
extraordinarily well drawn and that
doesn't mean they're likable yeah and
you know they they all have actual you
know real human failings and uh it is
notable that show in part because that
is so well done so you know it's it's
not like there hasn't been a problem
with regard to depiction of female
characters in movies and film and
there's some it's been much mocked but
there's some
female film critic has some rubric I
can't remember what it is but like you
know does does does this film have any
characters have any female characters
that aren't either sleeping with or you
know something like does it have any
female characters who just stand for
their own selves as opposed to
um they're basically a sidekick or an
afterthought or a sex interest or
something and
um
very often films don't but a that's
changing B it's going to depend on what
type of film it is and it this feels a
lot actually like
put into my computer like it's still up
there which it's not but it feels this
particular that that particular
page that I was on if I can find it
again did I close it and I would stop it
stupid inequality in 1300 popular films
this is specifically as far as I can
tell so far about oh no they just
started with sex and then they're going
to go on to the other ones
um as you say they're hard coding in a
moment in time and I think this is like
what we saw at Evergreen when they were
talking about what was going on in the
south from the 1950s with regard to race
relations it's like is anyone here
defending race relations in the south in
the 1950s no one is doing that how dare
you compare what is happening in a
progressive liberal arts campus in 2017
to what was going on in Mississippi in
1956 like how how dare you yeah right
well the thing is they're substituting
something for the way actual logic and
assessment is done yeah and they yeah
are inviting the criticism that there is
no problem on the basis that their
rubric for assessing that there is a
problem is garbage right right yes I'm
not saying there's no problem right but
you will notice that to the extent that
there have been great stories we don't
tell stories chosen at random we tell
great Stories the bias in access to
doing amazing stuff has been in favor of
men means that the historical backlog of
stories that we will probably tell on
film is biased towards men right does
that mean that women weren't doing
awesome things at those times Well to
some extent it might and to some extent
even that they were it didn't get
recorded So how do you tell those
stories well it takes so that's relevant
to historical stories that's not you
know most films aren't just trying to do
history it doesn't make any difference
the point is if you want to say across
films and history is some quantity we
are telling stories that actually
happened in some regard or plausibly
happened right then the point is okay
here you've got a fraction of total
films in which you would expect a bias
as you point out War films right do you
want
right but the point is to the extent
that you have categories that are
inherently biased like those two yeah
then the question is well
they're somewhere in your pile of films
that you're assessing and are saying is
biased and you don't know okay let's say
that there's a real problem and there
are films that are biased because of the
nature of History right you have to
figure you've got to subtract off the
fraction that are biased because history
is biased before you get to the part
that are biased for no reason yeah right
and so anyway it's a it's a nonsense
rubric that sounds rigorous it's it's
pseudo quantification yes it is
pseudo-quartification
and frankly
they don't need to convince most
creatives right because creatives
actually get to make decisions based on
their own preferences and their own
biases and say you know what I'm more
interested in a than b that's what I am
and I'm the creative and I'm gonna do
that and uh you know the other and then
maybe that's the director and then the
screenwriter more interested in a than b
and the actors more just Nathan B and
the choreographer and the editor and you
know and the set designers and everyone
else who's more interested in the a than
b goes into the a rather than the B
project
but and if there's just a lot fewer
people interested in b
that means that probably B doesn't get
done except that if you can convince the
studio head the people with the money
making the decision about we're going to
fund a versus B that even though there's
a lot less interest there's a lot less
Talent there's a lot lower chance that
you're actually going to make Bank on
this project over here we're going to do
that because if we aren't there's going
to be a mob outside our door telling us
we're racist yeah like that's how it's
done and
um you're therefore going to drive some
people who are over here in this
interest group to be like yeah I was
really interested in this all along
they're not going to do as good a work
if they aren't actually more interested
in this than this Yep they're like
they're not that's not the nature of
creativity and and productivity yep no
it's you know threatening creatives
threatening audiences right it's
basically a coercion uh in order to
create an on-screen world that doesn't
reflect either what the market wants or
reality right
yeah good job Websters
um
just watch the real Anthony fauci
documentary I didn't know there was a
documentary yep it's just recently
released
um damn is the end of that comment yeah
we haven't seen the documentary read the
book yeah damn damn
same I mean RFK is behind the
documentary
okay then you know if it's if it's put
together by the same crew
yeah I know people have seen it it
apparently is stunning as is the book
yeah
yeah and the book I mean the book
the book it's red full
not it's just so hard one page after
another and
we've talked we've said this so many
times on here but it's so well
researched yeah and you know I don't
I heart I did not check anything close
to a large fraction of the references
but I spot checked regularly yeah and I
never found an error
so I don't know anybody who has read it
who wasn't thrown by even people who are
welcome capture yeah yeah
okay I
Zach question hour an hour ten minutes
okay
um let's uh let's try to there's just a
few more comments here we won't get to
quite all the questions but almost all
of them a new merch idea just a black
shirt with white lettering hashtag I'm
afraid it's worse than that
yeah okay I could see the wisdom behind
that yep um someone will hopefully have
to write that down and send it to us
because I'm just hitting go here uh you
may know the other canoe metaphor a
popular joke among Canadians
how is American Beer like sexy sex in a
canoe it's uh uh [ __ ] close to water
yes
um
wow I hadn't realized that Penn had
fallen so far and to think that Solomon
Salman Rushdie was once the president of
Penn yeah this I did
there's a lot of rabbit warns to go into
uh with this story but yeah I agree I
thought that Penn uh was awesome when I
first started looking into that story
that we were talking about in the first
uh in the main live stream I thought
well pen you know they did the survey
and I went like whoa nope nope they are
not there just it's ideology top to
bottom
um
the flycatcher pick corresponds to a
tyrannus melancholicus commonly called a
tropical Kingbird that's cool so
tyrannis that's going to be tyranidae
which is the Tyrant fly Captain Tyrant
fly catchers I can't remember there's an
also a new world flycatcher family
there's an old worm fly catcher family
and then there's a tyrant flycatcher
like Tyrann a day and they're both like
fly catchers but they're not each
other's closest relatives just like
vultures older vultures newer vultures
um so I think flycatcher is kind of like
an ecological thing but also gets
applied to some lineages of birds not
all of which are actually each other's
closest relatives yep yeah fly catchers
and their foraging Sallys yes which uh
always
in my mind plays with the Mustang Sally
as the melody well and for me my memory
of foraging Sally my my introduction to
the concept of foraging salaries with
John Vandermeer who we were in uh Costa
Rica with our first we'd already
traveled through Central America on our
own but we were doing a
field course with him and for The
Graduate students and actually another
graduate student who was acting as his
ta basically he was touring us around a
bunch of
um well he was doing ecoag and biology
for a month or so uh in Costa Rica this
sort of like the summer of 94 I think
and
I didn't know any of the birds at that
point and I was standing with him and we
were looking at a bird and flew out and
grabbed an insect and flew back he said
that's a foraging Sally I was like okay
cool what's the Latin name of that
he's like it's the behavior you're more
interested in Behavior right like I I am
but I thought that was the name of the
birds
and I don't know what bird you're
looking at maybe it was it was maybe a
tournament yeah metallicus yeah uh it
may very well now I think it was
actually a smaller bird but anyway it
doesn't matter uh foraging Sally it
sounds like exactly the sort of name
that you were a bird a bird a a bird
watcher a bird person would give to a
bird totally and Mustangs okay there's
actually only two more questions so
we're gonna do them because the there's
three on here but one of them just says
hi Zach
hey Zach okay two more questions and
then we actually did all the questions
this week okay can you comment on
similarities of the state science today
and lysengoism
um another big question yeah I mean I
not really you know you've got two
different motivating forces you've got a
kind of a you know a top-down planned
economy this that and the other and then
from all appearances you've got the
capture of public institutions
by a lot a economic Goliath
so
you know Look What You've Got is
[ __ ] flowing through uh the public
um
advice
apparatus yeah and the motivations are
quite different I think I mean assuming
we are assuming the best which is that
this is just about pure corruption and
not about something else
um so anyway
yeah well I mean this is this is where I
keep doing the best this is about pure
corruption and nothing else yeah yeah I
don't um
this I think warrants more time another
time yeah
modern society runs on debit and credit
is this the basis of our cultural
decline
um
well I would say that's too simple
there is something to be said for the
idea that you know let's put it this way
economics with a profit bottom line May
simply if you don't have a
multi-dimensional currency okay the Mind
maintains values in a multi-dimensional
currency right you can be frightened and
excited
by the same opportunity and so those
things are not the same currency exactly
they net out to you either
pursue or don't but you maintain these
things separately for a reason a
currency that Nets out in one value
is potentially too dangerous it's it's
like optimizing for one value and the
point is the Carnage that comes from
that is immense it's not the same thing
as saying credit and and debt right it
it's closely related but there's
something in this neighborhood that may
just simply be
um to its reductionism of human values
and it may simply not work you may need
a multi-dimensional uh proxy
for things and it may be credit and
debit because it's because it reduces
because it reduces everything to the
metrics involved and inherently seeks to
commodify Human Experience and human
values yeah now on a related note I
heard Peter Thiel in some speech that he
recently gave I think the one in which
he
went to bat for cryptocurrencies
um
made up what I thought was an excellent
point about
the fact that we've got a problem that
comes from our currency being both a
store of value and a medium of exchange
and the idea that those two things might
need to be separated because where you
store your wealth and what you use to
you know to buy Kleenex are not
inherently the same thing right
um
so anyway I'm not sure where that fits
but I did think it was a useful
distinction
all right
we have our private q a on matrion
tomorrow at 11 A.M Pacific uh it's not
too late to join we've already got the
questions in hand but that's a small
enough and it's fun it is fun yeah and
it's a small enough group that we
um watch the chat and we interact with
the chat for those so you can join that
at my patreon also go to
darkhorsestore.org we're going to have
an update that do not affirm do not
comply uh
merch by tomorrow
and there's a bunch of other stuff that
we'll be getting more stuff up in time
for uh the holidays
I feel like I had one more announcement
but I cannot remember what it was we're
going to be back same time next week
to talk about whatever has happened and
respond yep and then do a q a and in the
meantime be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside hang in
there and if you need a haircut get one